il était au sommet du cyclisme mondial
avant de connaître une descente aux
enfers voici l'histoire de Marco Pantani
surnommé le pirate le meilleur grimpeur
de l'époque c'était Marcoing
et malheureusement une beaucoup de
mystères
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes le 5 juin 1999 au sommet
d'une étape de montagne du Giro le Tour
d'Italie
à deux jours de l'arrivée Marco Pantani
survole l'une des courses cyclistes les
plus difficiles au monde
il a jamais été aussi fort là c'était
vraiment la Pantani Mania il avait un
look pirate au début c'était il est
Fortino c'était moi moins glorieux parce
qu'il avait les oreilles décollées il
aimait pas trop normal donc le pirate ça
lui allait mieux on se souvient qui je
teste en bandana aussi au pied d'école
quand il allait attaquer pour ajouter un
petit peu à sa légende
sur les bords de la route Marco elle
manifico Marco le pirate des Dolomites
le roi de la montagne est acclamé
encouragé encensé par des milliers de
supporters des chaînés
en 1999 des contrôles sont mises en
place pour surveiller le taux
d'hématocrite des coureurs afin de
déceler le PO un produit dopant qui
stimule la fabrication des globules
rouges le leader du Tour d'Italie a été
exclu de la course ce matin après une
analyse sanguine suspecte ses
coéquipiers ont décidé d'abandonner le
Giro par solidarité il a toujours nié
d'avoir pris le poire il a pas été
contrôlé positif à une substance c'est
un taux et donc il estimait que les le
contrôle a été truqué en quelque sorte
son Minister
le criminel Renato valenciasca affirmera
que la mafia napolitaine qui aurait
parié de fortes somme d'argent sur l'un
des concurrents de Pantani serait à
l'origine de son exclusion du Giro le
rapport d'enquête d'un procureur italien
ayant interrogé plusieurs membres de la
mafia viendra confirmer cette thèse
[Musique]
en 1970 dans une famille modeste de chez
Zena en Roumanie une région située au
nord-est de l'Italie il grandit dans une
station balnéaire sur les bords de
l'Adriatique pour moi Marco Pantani
c'est un petit peu spécial je viens de
village voisin du sien donc on remercie
vaguement parce que l'hiver dans ces
stations balnéaire il y a vraiment il y
a personne donc tout le monde se connaît
plus ou moins c'était mon idole quoi il
faut le dire le coureur romagnol fait
son premier coup des Clash chez les
professionnels à 24 ans lors du Giro
1994 il mène la vie dure en haute
montagne à celui qui règne alors sur le
monde du cyclisme Miguel Indian deux
étapes du Giro
au pied au niveau quoi l'année suivante
il bat le record de la montée de l'Alpe
d'Huez l'une des ascensions les plus
mythiques du Tour de France mais
quelques mois plus tard il est victime
d'une collision avec une voiture lors de
la course Milan Turin il s'en sort avec
une double fracture tibia péronée
bas sont souvent dû à des chutes après
une année blanche consacrée à la
rééducation il chute de nouveau lors du
Giro 1997 en percutant un chat noir dans
une descente
il se remet en selle quelques semaines
plus tard lors du Tour de France où il
s'illustre de nouveau dans la montée de
l'Alpe d'Huez c'était sa montagne donc
on sait très bien quand il attaqué au
pied il y avait eu le riche il y avait
l'irank mais ciao Marco il s'en allait
et se retourner plus terminé en 37
minutes et 35 secondes le pirate donc
les 21 virages du sommet mythique
un record inégalé à ce jour il est
habité dans les ascensions on sent qu'il
y a une dimension supérieure qu'il porte
quand il s'envole vers la victoire le 27
juillet 1998 les coureurs du Tour de
France entame la 15e étape entre
Grenoble et les Deux Alpes sous la pluie
dans un froid glacial et Pantani entame
ce tour pas très bien et puis comme
souvent un petit à petit il monte en
pression jusqu'à cette fameuse étape des
Deux Alpes il y a des conditions météo
apocalyptiques à quelques kilomètres du
col du Galibier le pirate lance une
attaque qui restera dans la légende il
s'impose et relègue le maillot jaune
yannulrich à plus de 9 minutes
c'est vrai qu'il a renversé le tour
d'une manière incroyable ce jour-là et
il est rentré
dans la légende pas qu'en Italie quoi
dans la légende du cyclisme le grimpeur
italien encore grandi par son exploit
d'hier suscite une véritable Pantani
Mania grâce à son Pana c'est sa
générosité Marco Pantani est donc en
passe de rentrer à jamais dans la
légende du cyclisme au côté des plus
grands champions du siècle cette
année-là Marco Pantani remporte le Tour
de France quelques semaines après cette
imposée au Giro il a fait le doublé
d'iroto en 98 c'est très rare puisque
c'est personne ne l'a fait depuis donc
ça fait tout simplement 25 ans le tour
1998 est aussi marqué par l'affaire
Festina l'une des plus grandes affaires
de dopage de l'histoire du cyclisme
le sport Devil
tammente que le sportif j'ai perdu
après son exclusion du diront en 1999
suite à un antidopage Marco Pantani
revient sur le Tour de France l'année
suivante mais cette fois il doit faire
face au nouveau maître des lieux
l'Américain Lens Armstrong c'est
vraiment l'affrontement le choc en plus
entre deux univers complètement
différents l'italien romagnole contre le
Texan américain lors de la 12e étape
Lens Armstrong rattrape Marco Pantani
dans l'ascension du Mont Ventoux mais le
laisse finalement gagner on laisse pas
gagner Marco Pantani on peut le battre
mais on laisse pas gagner pour lui ça a
été un affront un déshonneur qui plus
aide la part de tout ce qui déteste un
lance armstron de l'américain arrogant
piqué au vif marque au Pantani remporte
l'étape entre Briançon et Courchevel 3
jours plus tard il dépose au passage le
coureur américain conférence de presse
Armstrong pour un peu sera acheté le
surnomme affectueusement illéphant de
Tino mais ça Pantani déteste
qui je suis qui est Marco Pantani qui
est prêt ouais ciao à l'orgueil et au
courage le pirate se lance lors de la
18e étape dans une échappée en solitaire
à 130 km de l'arrivée
toute son équipe parce qu'il avait peur
de Marco Pantani c'est le seul coureur
dont il avait peur dans les ascensions
épuisé par cet effort colossal Marco
Pantani finit par céder le lendemain il
abandonne le tour prétextant des
problèmes gastriques
on ignore encore avec précision si la
plus importante opération de police
menée en Italie sur une compétition
sportive aura été fructueuse ou pas le 6
juin 2001 en plein de Giro la police
italienne saisie dans les hôtels des
équipes plusieurs kilos de produits
[Musique]
donc suspension à nouveau etc triste fin
rattrapé par la justice pour plusieurs
affaires de dopage marque au Pantani
s'enfonce peu à peu dans la dépression
d'un peu un écorché vif et c'est senti
trahi vraiment en 99 c'est pourquoi moi
maintenant on sait qu'on parle beaucoup
de dépression du mal-être des sportifs
mais à l'époque non non
Pantani ne s'aime pas et ne supporte
plus son reflet au début de l'année 2003
il se fait opérer pour se faire recoller
les oreilles quelques mois plus tard il
fait un retour honorable au Giro mais en
coulisses le pirate n'est plus que
l'ombre de lui-même quelques jours après
la fin de la compétition il est
hospitalisé dans une clinique
psychiatrique l'ancien champion prend du
poids et consomme de fortes quantités de
cocaïne
il y a tout un environnement autour de
Marco Pantani qui était clairement pas
ça il y avait des mauvaises
fréquentations de façon on finit pas
dans cet état là si on est si on est
bien entouré
une tragédie pour l'Italie la une ce
matin de toute la presse transalpine le
champion Marco pentani est morte
un peu plus tôt dans la nuit le corps de
Marco Pantani était évacué sous les
applaudissements des typhoses
il a été retrouvé mort dans cette
chambre vers 21h30 depuis 4 jours le
cycliste était installé seul dans cet
hôtel à quelques kilomètres de son
village natal
il était capable de ressentir des choses
que peu de gens sont capables de
ressentir de se mettre dans des états
dans lesquels peu de gens sont capables
de se mettre donc de faire des exploits
incroyables la contrepartie c'était bah
il était capable de se mettre dans le
même état probablement mais dans le down
quoi overdose ou suicide on savait le
champion en pleine dépression depuis ses
problèmes de dopage avec la justice
italienne il était l'un des sportifs les
plus aimés d'Italie il est mort hier
soir seul dans une chambre d'hôtel Marco
pontani avait tout juste 34 ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]